our next speaker I'll say a few words
about
we'll be hearing from dr. Anita Sawyer
and she is a assistant professor
assistant clinical professor in our
department psychiatry a supervisor of
psychotherapy
she has a private practice full-time she
graduated [ __ ] laude from Yale College
she obtained her PhD here at Yale and
she's an author she's written several
works she's received literary awards for
them in the last few years she has begun
sharing her own personal journey through
issues of mental health and struggles
with our mental health system
particularly at the time when she when
she was doing that and she is here to
very bravely share her story I'm so
grateful to her as someone who is part
of our faculty to be here giving a
personal first-hand account of what it's
like to face some of the challenges that
we speak of here she has written a
memoir of her experience she is
currently working with publishers or
working with the process of establishing
which publisher will will publish this
work her current version of the memoir
is for sale here so in terms of conflict
of interest she's not making any money
off this but there are there are bound
copies of the memoir
and that is also over in the downstairs
on this side so people are welcome to
take a look at those and either way I
would strongly encourage you to keep an
eye out for her memoir when it is
published which will I think be
forthcoming in the next within these
next few years so I would like to invite
thank you very much Anita Sawyer dr.
Anita foyer
you can you hear me I'm honored to be
here
I can't imagine a greater affirmation
than the opportunity to speak and to be
heard I'll look at short and the
long-term consequences of a diagnosis of
borderline personality disorder and
other serious psychiatric conditions
using myself as a case study I
appreciate that you've just heard a list
of my accomplishments so I don't need to
tell you myself but I've always begun by
referring to my public record explaining
that I graduated from Yale and the first
class with women etc etc and then adding
that I've been married for almost 44
years that I have two adult children and
two grandchildren you can easily see the
defensive nough spite my adult
accomplishments despite my growing
confidence over time a part of me
continues to worry that when I tell you
I spent most of the years between ages
17 and 23 in two psychiatric hospitals
you'll feel that there's no need to
listen further you'll be inclined to
dismiss my words if not run in the
opposite direction as I feared when I
was younger my first public presentation
was in 2005 as a co-presenter with dr.
Michael stone at Cornell Columbia
psychiatry Grand Rounds in New York City
dr. stone a member of auto Kern Berg's
personality disorders research group and
a significant researcher in his own
right was presenting the results of his
study of hospitalized patients in New
York City from the 1960s who fit his
criteria for borderline personality
disorder I organized my talk around my
need to make clear that dr. stone was
mistaken to include me in his study I
don't think I'm alone in believing that
mental health profession
mewls no matter how compassionate and
understanding we might be with our
patients are among the most prejudiced
individuals when it comes to our own or
close family members psychiatric
conditions many of us struggle with
shame and strive to keep our difficulty
secret prejudice by definition
transcends reason I am here to challenge
this attitude
Michael stone and I had first met over
40 years earlier when he was beginning
his second year residency on the same
ward of Pi the New York State
Psychiatric Institute affiliated with
Columbia where I was an inpatient I was
21 years old at the time and had been
institutionalized for almost four years
dr. Stone's ultra long term follow-up
study included many dozens of patients
he had classified as borderline from PII
and similar institutions in the 1960s
and 70s some of these patients had made
it others had not a number of them were
successful many were dead in 1960 when I
was first hospitalized the diagnosis
assigned to me with schizophrenia much
of the treatment I was given made me
worse and for many years my prognosis
was described as extremely poor
nevertheless as you can see I was one of
the very lucky ones who survived and
succeeded but I always have trouble
keeping my voice how is it that I am
successful and not dead what enables one
person to overcome a significant
adversity while the next one can't and
most important how can we as clinicians
as patients I hope you don't mind but
I'll continue to use the term patient
for the person being treated because
that's how I used to be
how can we influence the outcome by
describing what happened to me I'll give
you some possibilities to consider I
bring a unique perspective I can speak
both as the doctor who seeks to heal and
as the patient who surmounted the odds
whether you're the therapist or the
patient a parent a sibling or a close
friend
I offer my story as encouragement as a
source as a resource for sustaining
yourself during those times when you
might feel overwhelmed and want to stop
working so hard that's when we treat to
stereotypes become tempting because I've
been part of both worlds as desperate
patient and experienced therapist I
speak the language of each one I want to
offer help with translation and to
facilitate understanding my story
illustrates how easily in the early
1960s an anxious dissociated severely
suicidal adolescent could have been
misdiagnosed with schizophrenia and then
could have been given shock treatment
this happened because trauma was not
well understood because sexual abuse was
barely acknowledged and because the
available treatments at the time
determined the diagnosis given this last
remains true today although some of the
treatments and diagnoses have changed if
I have one message to offer you
especially for therapists but for
families as well it is to pay mindful
attention to listen and learn the
language of the patient rather than
trying just to apply what you think you
already know the poets and artists and
anthropologists among you those who are
comfortable with ambiguity who are open
to unusual alternative worlds may find
ways to communicate with difficult
individuals that enable them to feel
understood my concern about diagnostic
labels is that they can too easily
become a refuge from the pain
humiliation and frustration as well as
the satisfaction and joy of grappling
with a
real person diagnosis is useful for
setting the scene but it does not write
the script I speak as a clinician who
certainly has made my share of mistakes
I know there are not always answers and
that what we believe and trust today may
not may prove misguided even harmful
tomorrow but I'm passionate about the
danger of making assumptions rather than
paying attention
accepting stereotypes rather than doing
the hard work of being open to each
unique individual again my message is
this never sit back and think you have
it all figured out but pay attention
keep an open mind and don't give up I
also speak as someone who was a very
close call now over fifty years ago in
1960 I had just turned 17 when I was
admitted to a psychic a prestigious
local psychiatric hospital and given a
diagnosis of schizophrenia other type
depressed I'd swallowed 14 aspirin a few
months earlier this time my mother had
read in my diary that I was going to
drown myself during a Memorial Day
weekend at the beach with my high school
friends it was so long ago that one
report gives me a diagnosis of dementia
praecox I've been active in my high
school I'd had leading roles in school
plays was an editor of the literary
journal worked on the yearbook was
active in the Honor Society etc my
friends were what today we call the
smart alternative students yet for seven
several months prior to the hospital
admission I had been shrinking my
handwriting got smaller and smaller
gradually the differentiation between
lowercase and capital letters
disappeared my English teacher told me
he'd no longer read my papers if I
continued to write like that my voice
volume diminished until I was almost
inaudible I stopped speaking in the
first person I couldn't say the word
in the hospital I admitted I wanted to
die but I was unable to articulate my
reasons for this beyond saying that I
was crummy and bad my thinking and
ability to express myself had shrunk
along with my voice and my handwriting
all I wanted to do was disappear the
hospital psychological testing report
referred to my slipping into a quicksand
like illness deeply depressed with
suicidal preoccupations and fantasies
along with suicidal ideation my symptoms
included insomnia depersonalization and
derealization we would say now that I
was varied
I was described as shy fearful
obsequious dependent and infantile
emotionally while my inability to
express myself was identified as
stubborn stubborn resistance and
withholding my inaccessibility annoyed
and frustrated the psychiatrist treating
me less than two weeks after being
admitted I was started on a course of 25
EC T's I began to experience
hallucinations my nightmares increased
during the day I remained passive and
withdrawn if I had arrived 20 years
later in 1980 let's say I would probably
have been diagnosed with borderline
personality disorder
another critical diagnosis associated
with permanent disability which had
achieved prominence by then 20 years
after that in 2000 perhaps these same
symptoms might have led to a diagnosis
of bipolar disorder although some few
might have suspected PTSD I might be I
might be given any of these diagnoses if
my young self turned up today depending
on how much information was available
and who was diagnosing me but focusing
on pathological symptoms in order to
arrive at a diagnosis can interfere with
seeing clearly the whole person in front
of you it makes it easy to lose heart
and to miss positive resources
that might serve as anchors for the
therapeutic alliance and provide fuel
for the creative energy necessary to
sustain that alliance I believe that a
diagnosis can be useful because it
provides an organizing framework but we
mustn't forget that it is our construct
not some objective truth giving an
adolescent or anyone for that matter a
psychiatric diagnosis has serious
consequences the most immediately
obvious is that diagnosis informs
treatment and the wrong treatment can be
harmful for an unformed adolescent you
are also influencing in a profound way
their intimate self definitions a way of
looking at themselves with that will
likely take hold for the rest of their
lives that is no small effect I was
discharged from the hospital almost 47
years ago yet might if my defensive
introduction shows you I still need to
make sure no one thinks I'm a
psychiatric that my psychiatric history
means I'm a crazy person without
authority to say what I have to say my
point is simple stigma is real and
shamed sticks in the 1950s and 60s
schizophrenia was a very frequently
applied diagnosis it was used for
out-of-control rebellious dope-smoking
teenagers whose parents didn't know what
to do with them and it was used for
withdrawing socially isolated youngsters
who were depressed and suicidal some
like myself although I didn't know it
consciously at the time were fleeing
abusive situations in their homes
treatment for schizophrenia included
medication often electroshock treatment
and sometimes psychotherapy so over
medicated teenagers were one consequence
for many of us it was also shock
treatment which affected our brains and
destroyed short-term memory and for me
the shot treatment itself was traumatic
I understood that ECT it induced a
seizure by sending electrical impulses
into the brain I've
figured that all it took was a slight
miscalculation to end up electrocuted as
a consequence I approached every single
treatment terrified I was sure I was
about to be killed
I showed no initial improvement with the
ECT and I developed some symptoms in the
hospital that had not been evident prior
to my admission such as hallucinations
and stuttering serious clumsiness and
eventually seizures I looked like I was
12 although I was 17 when I was admitted
I was smart but I talked pretty dumb
expressing myself more like a
six-year-old than a high achieving
youngster of 17 or 20 I was determined
to die not to escape my own pain but to
atone for my sins no one stepped back to
look at these as valuable clues as
messages that I could not communicate
with words yet was refusing to
relinquish I was acting out in metaphor
what I could not know or say directly
similarly on the level of metaphor the
hospital doctors delivering shock
treatment were unwittingly repeating the
abusive behavior I was fleeing
reinforcing the message that I deserve
to be punished and should never speak
about or even recognize what I knew
after several dismal months I was
assigned to a new young psychiatrist who
was lively and liked me slowly I began
to get better I had been admitted in May
and I returned to school complete my
junior year the following April
commuting from the hospital I returned
to live at home on an extended visit a
six-month pass and in June just a year
after my admission that fall I was
elected president of my high school
National Honor Society
I had a leading role in the school play
I was an illustrator for the yearbook
I took honors classes then less than two
months into my senior year senior year I
began to have seizures and dissociative
episodes
school I began to slip after about seven
months at home in January 1962 I was
readmitted to the hospital intensely
suicidal my condition had deteriorated
significantly all my apparent gains had
been lost I was given shock treatment
more shot treatments and deteriorated
further I began to act out in
increasingly blatant self-destructive
ways eventually after three more courses
of ECT
adding up to an overall total of 89
shock treatments before I was 20 I
continued to lose ground and the
hospital decided that they could do
nothing more for me I was identified as
unimproved luckily for me my mother's
best friend from place from grade school
was now married to the lieutenant
governor of the state of New York so I
was transferred to PI a State Hospital
and Columbia's teaching hospital the
director of P I made clear in a letter
that he was accepting me because he was
required to do so and really and not to
hold him or p.i accountable if I failed
to improve which he anticipated given my
dangerously suicidal condition and my
extremely poor prognosis by this time I
lost almost all memory of my life prior
to the hospitalizations when I arrived
at P I I was 20 years old and I couldn't
answer the question of how many weeks
were in a year at P I I was not given
shock treatment which was a relief but I
was assigned to a psychiatry resident
with whom I couldn't connect
we didn't respect one another I
continued to act out alternating between
passive withdrawal and episodes of
smashing my head against the wall I
swallowed glass I burned myself with
cigarettes scratched my face bit my
hands and pressed them against radiators
to burn them I held my breath and
I passed out I had nightmares and
screamed in my sleep I had lost pretty
much all memory of my early years what
remained was only a global sense of fear
I was seriously dissociated dominated by
feeling completely unreal myself and
experiencing the world around me as
unreal as well I thought I was evil I
hated myself and assumed everyone else
did too I'm sure at times that the staff
experienced me as completely impossible
I was often beyond reach after I've been
at pi/4 about six months I made a
significant suicide attempt while I was
home on a weekend pass after that I
didn't go home even to visit for close
to a year in July 1964 after almost a
year at p.i I was assigned to a new
psychiatry resident Stanley Heller was
someone I liked and respected I thought
he was handsome and smart and he talked
to me I felt that he took me seriously
he didn't talk down to me or lecture me
his sense of humor matched mine when I
made stupid puns he laughed when I told
him that evil garbage stank and should
be eliminated he told me he knew someone
who looked for treasures in garbage one
person's stink is another's perfume dr.
Heller noted astonishing me humiliation
and shame could be interrupted if only
briefly by my admiration for his
cleverness
I continue to act out in
self-destructive ways but his response
to me was direct and real what a pain in
the neck he said once after I battered
my head yet again I had to laugh at
myself in the spark of a good joke we
were peers we connected he was not
blaming or intrusive with my with
interpretations of my motives instead he
was straightforward and looked at what I
had done and asked why now how come what
are you doing as if he thought there
were understandable reasons for my
actions that we could figure out
together when I did something
particularly dangerous he showed that he
cared that I had been hurt and he
expressed his anger in a way that showed
showed me that he worried about me I had
been unlucky and that I was misdiagnosed
and the treatment traumatized me but I
was lucky that in the late 1960s along
with medication and shock treatment in
the teaching hospitals there was an
enormous investment in psychotherapy as
treatment so eventually I was able to
connect with dr. Stanley Heller and to
begin to find myself a colleague asked
me if I could explain how as a patient I
differentiated the psychiatric residence
I respected from those I did not I think
I can safely speak for most of us at the
time when I say that I could sense which
residents were afraid of patients and
which were comfortable with themselves
and with patients as fellow humans
I could tell who was speaking past me
mouthing empty phrases without noticing
if I was listening closed and aloof
afraid of being contaminated if touched
the finest therapists understood their
work to be a collaboration with each
patient they weren't afraid to journey
together through an unknown and possibly
dangerous land subjectively when I felt
understood and respected that is taken
seriously which was infrequent I was
grateful and in return I gave that
person
doctor or nurse enormous respect they
also got my loyalty I gave them room to
be imperfect in subsequent interactions
as long as they were honest and real
feeling understood is the essence of
connection and ultimately it's this
connection that carries healing an
example of this ability to connect comes
from a set of interviews I had with
Harold Searles in late night in late
1964 Harold Searles was an
internationally recognized psychiatrist
considered a master clinician who
pioneered counter transference and
treating psychotic and borderline
patients at the time he was the clinical
supervisor for my psychiatrist Stan
Heller in the first interview Jones made
references to my shrinking self effacing
demeanor and behavior on the ward and
told me I acted like I wanted to be a
saint I don't remember that interview
beyond my thinking that he was a nun
comprehending jerk but there was a
second interview and that one I've
always remembered and credited and I
knew this even at the time somehow with
changing my life in the second interview
Harold Searles referred to my interest
in being perfect the Saint thing and
then he remarked that I appeared to him
like a frightened young fawn deer in the
headlights my frozen innocence and fear
made him feel like a dirty old man he
told me and this made him feel so bad
about himself that he wanted to kill
himself one remarkable feature of this
exchange as I would later understand is
that unconsciously I had communicated
and he had received the essence of the
truth that was unknown to me at the time
my paralyzing fear was indeed connected
with a dirty old man and was driving my
obsession with suicide a transcript of
this interaction might appear bizarre or
quite inappropriate
however for me although I couldn't
explain it consciously
dr. Searles made contact I felt
connected and understood the life
changing aspect was the idea that I
could affect the feelings of someone
else especially in this case a respected
Authority I had caused him to feel
something for someone who felt as if she
floated alone in the universe unreal and
completely without influence this was a
new concept that night following the
interview I told the other patients
gathered at our informal evening coffee
discussion group what had happened he
said I made him feel guilty like a dirty
old man like I was some kind of Saint
can you imagine hell yes said one you're
always doing stuff for other people
yeah chimed in another you do that right
here when someone sneezes who's the
first of governing for a tissue it's
sickening don't you realize you make us
feel like we're not as good as you do
when you do that all the time like you
have to be better yeah I feel useless
sometimes like you have to get there
first to help one after another my
friends and even some patients I hardly
knew gave examples of my oppressive
helpfulness I'm still a little like that
at first I felt bewildered but I got it
I think my awareness that I had an
effect on other people began my healing
I experienced myself differently I
observed myself interacting working with
dr. Heller who had laid the groundwork
and whom I trusted as my guide I was on
my way after I turned this important
corner
what registered with me were the times
when dr. Heller's stepped beyond his
white coat if you will they really wore
white coats then and treated me as if I
were a reasonable person not a mental
patient I suppose as translator I'd say
that when I refer to being seen as a
mental patient
it meant I felt I was being treated as a
less than human object but dr. Heller
spoke to me as one whole person to
another and he noticed the healthy part
of me
gradually I could tell he believed in my
strength he believed that I could make
it make a life for myself outside of
institutions I knew he was showing me
how healthy people interact toward the
end of that second year at p.i when the
July rotations were approaching I
realized that I might possibly remain
dr. Heller's patient if I got my
behavior under control
similarly I understood that if I failed
to control myself
I'd have no chance to continue treatment
with him I managed to succeed well
enough and I remained his patient
through the rest of his residency a year
later I knew I had to be well enough to
be discharged in order to continue to
work with him after he left bi and
opened his private practice I moved out
of Pi the day before my 23rd birthday
about six weeks before July 1st dr.
Heller and I continued to work together
for the next five years I was employed
at several retail and then clerical jobs
during the year I was leaving PI as a
patient in a state mental hospital I was
eligible for state services and through
the Department of vocational
rehabilitation
Billiton I was sent for psych testing
although still diagnosed as
schizophrenic I would I was considered
bright enough for college so they sent
me to school that's where really the
good old days the next year I began
college at the school of general studies
at Columbia at school I met the man who
was to become my husband we fell in love
after a courtship developed from our
intellectual kinship we reveled in
discussions about our sociology class
and the concepts and theories we were
learning there two years later I married
him and moved to New Haven where he was
going to attend graduate school at Yale
in sociology Yale College was accepting
transfer students for the upper classes
as part of its first year as a
co-educational college of course I was
rejected as a transfer student however
as a Yale spouse I was allowed to attend
classes as a special student I spent
most of my junior year walking around
with a giant chip on my shoulder I
should have been grateful and in many
ways I was but all I saw were beautiful
young women whose applications had not
been rejected and I was envious
Yale's transition to co-education was
difficult and many women left
a year later Yale reopened admissions
for transfer students I applied again
and this time I was accepted to
celebrate dr. Hillier brought a half
bottle of champagne to our session and
we toasted the momentous occasion
he also got he was afraid to tell his
supervisors it was a marvelous
affirmation of my assertiveness and
adult accomplishment in 1971 I graduated
with the first class of Yale women summa
[ __ ] laude Phi Beta Kappa with highest
honors in sociology this intern opened
further doors for me by encouraging
people to take me seriously to give me a
chance when other aspects of my history
might have made them shy away from
investing in me I was determined to
become a psychologist myself and my
journey to achieve that goal also
involved Sara serendipity good fortune
and having those who believed in me and
sheer grit and determination on my part
stubbornness actually I applied and was
initially rejected for a graduate
psychology program and then for the
clinical psychology internship
essentially I proved absolutely
determined I refused to stop trying
until various directors in various
programs said okay if she wants that
this much why not let her and then let
my not let her do it and then I did it
for the first two years after I was
married and living in New Haven I
commuted to New York City to see dr.
Heller then I knew it was time for me to
learn more about how to be a woman and
with his blessing I transferred to a
female psychiatrist in New Haven she and
I worked together for the next ten years
while I cried I attended graduate school
did my internship had my babies and
carried out my dissertation in 1981
after twenty-one years of therapy I
stopped three months prior to my last
appointment I had a transformative
experience while on the way to my
session I suddenly found myself
intensely vividly alive and present the
depersonalization vanished I was real it
was as if the world suddenly took on
color when before I'd known only
shades of grey when I terminated three
months later for the first time in my
life I felt I was truly on my own at the
same time I knew that my therapist was
still there for me if I needed her that
fall I finished my dissertation and was
hired by a child psychiatrist expanding
his clinic I joined him and his partner
the psychologist the late psychologist
Daniel Miller who became my supervisor
and mentor I've worked full-time ever
since
first with that practice and since 1990
on my own I spent those years learning
from my patients and always trying to
understand what it is that leads to
people getting well a few years ago 40
years after I had been first admitted to
the hospital I seemed to be successful
personally and professionally I proven
to myself that I'd made it but I
continued to live with what felt like
the shameful secret of my hospital
experience and the reality that I still
had no memories of my childhood most of
my first 20 years I avoided talking
about my youth generalizing and
confabulating when necessary from facts
I've been told or read about myself
only a few people knew about my history
and psychiatric hospitals or my
extensive psychotherapy after that my
children were grown and on their own I
decided it was time to find out about my
lost life I was ready to confront my
past so I sent for my hospital records
and I read them as an experienced
clinician I recognized immediately what
the doctors hadn't been able to see in
1960 my problem wasn't schizophrenia but
incest once I encountered the clinical
reality of my early situation I started
to remember what I had assumed had been
lost forever my memory had not been
destroyed by the shock treatment after
all but had been repressed or
dissociated even before I was
hospitalized I realized I'm a sort of
illustration of
everything that you've heard you know
before this about memory and etc however
confronting the truth of my
circumstances via the records profoundly
retraumatization I developed flashbacks
and nightmares was beset with intrusive
images and became very anxious subject
to emotional flash floods of grief and
despair I lost interest in the world
around me I was focused only on finding
out who I was and what had happened to
me my various perspectives all came
together when I read my hospital records
and discovered the trauma in myself in
the present I had known myself as a
mature seasoned therapist who listened
to her patients with an informed
compassionate understanding of the whole
organic process accepting the painful
ups and downs in the short-term by
holding on to the big picture now I also
knew the immediate pristine existential
perspective of the same woman who
couldn't believe what was happening to
her in her own present life I was caught
off guard when I read my records I had
no idea I could be so unsettled I
thought that I was well analyzed and
prepared to deal with anything life
might bring to me in fact I was pretty
naive throughout this time I continued
to work full-time in my psychology
practice I had my own individual therapy
and the psychologist part of me was
observing and aware of what was
happening to me but the need to pull
myself together
in order to be present and true to my
professional commitment in my office is
an important part of how I survived as
well as I did each day no matter how
dismayed I felt I had to summon my adult
strength so that I could be present for
the people who needed me because I was
working with a skilled and experienced
therapist in my own psychotherapy and
recovery is an orderly process with time
I emerged from the other side my
symptoms receded
and I regained an interest in the world
outside myself some of the emotional
intensity of my experience even though
it was relatively recent disappeared
and as with childbirth or a terrible
nightmare only the intellectual
awareness that I experienced some
feelings beyond ordinary comprehension
remains the essence of my interest in
describing these things to you is to
emphasize that we always have to pay
mindful attention what happened to me
initially was a failure to pay attention
and what ultimately enabled me to
recover each time came from informed
careful exquisitely personal attention
the diagnosis and treatments may change
today it may be borderline or bipolar
rather than schizophrenia and the
treatment may be powerful pills
rather than shock treatment but with
today's pressures there will always be
the temptation to think that you know
the answer without really looking at the
particular individual in front of you
and to put him or her into the category
at hand because you have the latest
drugs to prescribe or the newest therapy
to apply these seemingly innocent errors
can have devastating consequences and
even if you have the right diagnosis
everyone needs to be known as a whole
unique person no one cures a diagnosis
what my guiding clinicians had in common
was their own self-awareness and
self-confidence
it took paying attention looking me in
the eye and not being afraid to learn
who I was each of them was authentically
him or herself they were real they had
faith in their own ability to act
spontaneously in the moment often the
moment was one of humor and sharing a
play on words or sarcastic observation
about someone else even about me I was
just one of two adults enjoying each
other's company securing that brief
exchange that we were truly
communicating for those seconds I wasn't
alone in the universe unreal and
unattached those
seconds were precious and I remembered
them these therapists also showed that
they cared they won't print off entirely
by am i annoying mannerisms they chose
not to dismiss me as manipulative but to
see the frightened child underneath we
don't do things for no reason I tell my
patients I was a scary and frustrating
patient but I was trying to communicate
the therapists who make a difference
didn't overlook the messages in my
behavior or disregard my tremendous
neediness they were very patient when I
hurt myself they got angry in a way
which communicated that their anger had
to do with their not wanting me to cause
myself more pain and when I got better
they believed in me although it along
with compassion for my pain they
appreciated my strength my intelligence
and my quirky sense of humor and they
each have remained a part of my life
concretely affirming my value as a
healthy adult I didn't have to stay sick
to know them this is one of the most
important aspects of the therapy I
learned from my mentor the late
psychologist Daniel Miller who
philosophically understanding that
defenses are symptoms personal style and
perceptions of the world are rich
sources of information about old
relationships and reflect past and
present strengths this is the essential
model of wellness of respect for
survival and focus on the tools that
make survival and growth possible the
stubbornness that had me relentlessly
pursuing my death that led my earlier
psychiatrists to characterize me as
withholding or resisting shock treatment
is the very same determination that has
led to my professional accomplishments
my writing my book and my speaking here
today as Stanley Heller recently
reminded me what really matters is how
well you are not how sick you are
I didn't suffer from schizophrenia I may
or may not have had a borderline
personality disorder these and several
other diagnoses share many symptoms with
complex post post-traumatic stress
sorter which I did experience twice
however to focus only on symptoms or on
PTSD itself is a trap it's by setting
labels aside by paying attention to the
person right there and holding yourself
open to possibility that you can save
the lives of people like me